[Musique]
[Rires]
tout va bien
de vieux campeur gallia seront présents
merci lyon
[Musique]
à l'origine était le chaos la terre gaïa
pour les grecs puis la première entité
en émerger c'est donc la plus grande des
divinités me créer ni enfanté apparu
sans l'aide de personne
elle porte les sommets les plus hauts et
les gouffres les plus profonds
[Musique]
ces lieux sauvages sont inviolables
protégé par des forces divines
ils ne sont pas faits pour les humains
les uns dominant le monde sont associés
au règne des dieux les autres insondable
et obscure aux malheurs et à la mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la montagne vers laquelle le regard
s'élève est le lieu privilégié la
spiritualité qu'elle soit religieuse ou
non les sommets inaccessibles à la
plupart des mortels sont les lieux les
plus mystérieux qui soit les sentiers
empreinte l'école mais jamais les
sommets s'y rendre est un choix en même
temps qu'une épreuve le cheminement est
long souvent difficile parfois périlleux
[Musique]
l'accès au sommet peut alors
s'apparenter au pèlerinage l'effort
physique et morale devenant une
illustration de la dévotion qui anime le
grimpeur une fois atteint les sommets
sont investis de symboles témoigne de la
réussite de l'entreprise
kern croit chapelle voir monastère
gigantesque
[Musique]
merveilles de la nature wander de gaia
ce sont les assises des dieux
[Musique]
l'altitude aboli une partie de la
frontière entre l'humain et le divin
c'est la proche au sens physique du
terme des forces supérieures et
primitive puisque le cas aux grands
tours originelles peut aussi désigner
l'espace séparant le ciel de la terre
pourtant c'est en accrochant de cette
frontière qu'elle se matérialise
vraiment atteindre le promontoire au
prix d'un effort important rappelle aux
pèlerins sa condition de mortel
l'essoufflement de la montée une
courtier presse au sommet la nécessaire
redescente sa place n'est pas en
[Rires]
monsieur
[Musique]
on
pour les grecs de l'antiquité ce sommet
lieu par excellence du mythe et de la
religion c'est l'olympe olimpo ce
étymologiquement coupant le passage où
entouré par les nuages tient son nom de
sa réalité géographique cette montagne
est une frontière physique et psychique
qui sépare le monde divin du monde
humain frontière physique d'abord
puisque l'olympe est un ensemble de
sommer qui surplombe la plaine de
macédoine et s'élève à 2917 m avec le
pic du midi casse frontières psychique
ensuite car ce point culminant d'un pays
montagneux a été choisie pour héberger
les douze dieux du panthéon locale
c'est là que les secrets sont gardés les
décisions prises les destins celle ci
d'elfes et le centre du monde
mythologique l'olympe en est la capitale
atteindre le sommet c'est donc pour nous
atteindre la connaissance briser le
secret du divin voir ce qui par
définition est retranché à la vue et
tout devient clair
[Musique]
pour une fois à la question que nous
posons dans cette odyssée la réponse est
simple que découvrent les archéologues
sur l'olympe rien sur le lieu le plus
cité des récits héroïques à l'endroit
mythique par excellence
pas de vestiges mais ne faisons pas
semblant d'être étonné ce n'est pas une
surprise
l'ascension n'aura fait que confirmer ce
que nous savions déjà
le rappel de cette évidence par
l'expérience sensorielle par la présence
sur les lieux permet de nous convaincre
définitivement des intuitions que nous
avions eu ailleurs les mythes et les
vestiges archéologiques ne perd pas dans
le même monde
l'illusion de la correspondance entre
les vieilles légendes et les vieilles
pierres ne peut plus tenir sur l'olympe
aboutissement de notre voyage ultime
épreuve dressé sur notre route
la montagne sacrée révèle la supercherie
cette montagne n'abrite aucun dieu
d'elle ce n'est pas le centre du monde
oedipe n'a pas chassé la sphinge
agamemnon n'a pas régné sur miss aisne
athènes n'a pas vu s'affronter les dieux
pour al santorin abrite aucune atlantide
englouti ni knossos aucun homme tôt la
réalité est tout autre
ce sont des villes des palais et des
sanctuaire érigé parcouru et oublier
parfois par des sociétés très ancienne
redécouvert il révèle une extrême
complexité et leur connaissance
approfondie n'est possible qu'au prix
d'un travail long et méticuleux très
loin des récits mythiques et de leur
verdict définitif
malgré tout et sachant cela depuis le
début nous avons joué le jeu le jeu de
la mythologie car c'est la porte
d'entrée de la connaissance
le mythe s'il ne correspond à aucune
réalité historique remplit tout de même
de fonctions indispensables
d'abord c'est une publicité la meilleure
qui soit s'intéresserait ton autant à
akrotiri sans mythe de l'atlantide que
nous sauce accueillir est elle autant de
visiteurs sans cette histoire d'hommes
taureau ce serait non seulement arrêté à
ted
si ce n'est pour deep sans doute pas
[Musique]
mais ensuite et plus important encore le
mythe et notre aide mémoire ce sont les
récits qui porte les images et les
émotions qui sont le support de la
mémoire
les éléments mystère et de fantastique
son talent autant d'à croche pour le
souvenir futur
plus que les chiffres et les détails
scientifiques
[Musique]
m
cherché à replacer les événements
décrits par les mythes dans la
chronologie de l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est manqué sa cible puisqu'il ne sont
pas du même monde monde des idées et des
songes pour limite non des découvertes
matériel ou factuelles pour les sciences
vouloir les confondre est une tentation
compréhensible un discours
sensationnaliste remporte toujours
l'entousiasme au contraire vouloir trop
séparer ces deux mondes imagination et
raison c'est prendre le risque
d'enfermer les sciences dans leurs
discours technique de les marginaliser
convoqué limite sans y souscrire mais en
sachant ce qu'on leur doit
voilà peut-être une juste réconciliation
[Musique]
m
d'où venez vous d'où venez vous d'où
venez vous
m
d'où venez vous
le mans
pour anna vous pourrez vous pourrez
n'avoue pour enrique dorénavant
pour vous
[Musique]
oh